hi I'm Mark Wilson Thomas and I'm a
program manager on the Visual Studio
Intelli code team I'm here today to
share with you some ways in which we're
making developers more productive using
the power of machine learning and
advanced pattern matching techniques so
just to take a quick look here we're
working with developers who have
struggled with getting to code with
confidence to find their issues in their
code faster and to focus their code
reviews and we've got answers to many of
those questions what we allow you to do
is to leverage the wisdom of the
community that you're working in in
terms of its code base and bring it to
bear at your point of need writing your
code editor okay
so that what that allows you to do is to
get very very context-sensitive
recommendations for the code that you're
going to write we can also search inside
the code that you're typing right there
locally on your machine and look for
repeated patterns that you might be
creating whilst you code those things
are then used to spot places elsewhere
in your code where the same their change
might be required we call that repeated
edits detection and that's using a
technology called pros which is a
program synthesis by example that is the
same tech that is used in Excel to do
that flash fill feature where you fill
out lots of examples of something so
let's take a look at a quick demo so
here I'm going to show you I'm working
on a little function here and the
function I'm working on is going to
strip some cat some characters from some
code do a little bit of normalization
and you'll see if I place my caret right
here and bring up intellisense I see
these recommendations which are coming
from Intelli code and you'll see that
the one that it's recommending is
replaced here this is based on the
context that I'm in okay but watch what
happens as I start to work further down
my code if I say if path dot I'll see a
different list to the one that I saw
before that's pretty cool because
actually it knows that I'm in the
context of an if and I can say ends with
and go ahead and put in the thing that
I've just replaced to search for it it
gets even better though if I start to
then go ahead and take an operation
based on that I'm now inside the context
of an if block and again the
context is different so the
recommendations are different so I'm
getting recommendations based on what
the open source community knows about my
code I can then go even further and
start to fill out the parameters for
this method and sure enough it even
knows that length is the most logical
one for here where I'm looking for an
integer okay so that's intellicus
recommendations in a nutshell we even
provide you with the ability to train on
your own source code and get
recommendations for your own types and
that's a service that we're adding and
you can get to that simply by going here
and typing Intelli code and you'll bring
up this screen which will allow you to
create models based on your own code and
see completions for your own types I
also mentioned the repeated edits and I
just want to show you a quick one of
those right now if I am refactoring some
code here and I go ahead and start doing
that work and I've got some other
instances of this further down my file
and at this point in time as a developer
I'm feeling pretty depressed because
I've got to go and find every single one
of them and I might go ahead and write a
regular expression to go find those but
honestly debugging that regular
expression might actually take me longer
than going and finding them so what I've
noticed here is though that prose is on
my side the repeated edits detector has
detected the other places for me and
better still it can actually go ahead
and make the fix right there in the code
for me because it just found my pattern
and helped me out so I've leveraged the
wisdom of even the code that I was
typing on the fly to get things done
this is just getting started for Intel
acade I encourage you to hit us up at
AKA ms Intelli code to learn more and
get in contact with us if you want some
more information you can download the
extension for visual studio and for
visual studio code today thanks a lot